لم يكتفي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بتدمير
بيوتهم ودفعهم للنزوح قصرا الى مراكز
الاواء بل لاحقهم في هذه المراكز ليقتلهم
ويصيبهم ويدفعهم للنزوح مره اخرى نستمع
الى هذه الروايات طبعا كانوا يقولون ل
مكان امن امم متحده ومكان يعني مؤمن دوليا
واحداثيات معانا هذا كلام الوكاله من
اربعه ايام هم بيطلقوا نار كثيف كل يوم
بتصوب ناس في الصناع
يوميا بعد اطلاق النار بقوللك خبط قذيف
الدبابه في ناس ما تتحرق واحنا قاعدين
بدنا نطلع من المكان خضب قذيفه في المبنى
اللي انا تحتيه وصارت الناس على الارض
مرميه الله يحك من
وكاله
تم تهجيرنا من بيت لاهيا الى منطقه خان
يونس
في في منطقه صناعه خان يونس التابعه للان
روا وقد تعرضنا خلال الايام الماضيه لشتى
انواع العذاب من من القصف الذي يحيط بنا
ومن الرصاص الطائش الذي كاد ان يصيبنا في
الايام الفائته لولا ستر الله بنا
وبعائلتي وبعد ان قمنا بصلاه الفجر جلسنا
اح نحن والاسره مع بعضنا البعض وكان ابنه
ابن بنت ويبلغ من العمر اربع شهور دائما
كنت احب ان اداعبه فكنت جالس على الارض وه
وهو بجانبي وكنت لاعبه وفجاه واذا برصاصه
الغدر الصهيونيه تلطم وجهي اخترقت الجانب
من الجانب الايسر من عيني من هنا ها هنا
واخترقت جو الانف والجيوب الانفيه واستقرت
في هذا المكان كما تشاهدون وبدا الدم يشر
من انف في سالني اولادي وجيراني الى اقرب
نقطه في في المنطقه اللي هي التابعه لنقطه
الصحه في في منطقه الانروا اللي في
منطقه الصناعه ولكن قالوا لا يوجد هناك اي
تنسيق للرواه في هذه المنطقه لا غرابه
فيما يحدث في مراكز الاواء في قطاع غزه
فهذه الافعال تثبت من جديد بان هذا هو
الوجه الحقيقي لاسرائيل والهدف الاسمى هو
القتل والاباده لكل ما هو فلسطيني هاني
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح